launching airstrikes against Islamic
state from a base in Cyprus protecting
commercial ships passing through the
Strait of Gibraltar defending the
Falkland Islands key tasks carried out
by Britain's Armed Forces that could be
affected if an Odile brexit obstructs
the flow of supplies to troops overseas
to counter the risk the Ministry of
Defence has started stockpiling extra
food fuel spare parts and even
ammunition it is important for the
country for the general who commanded
British forces to victory against
Argentina in the Falklands it's sensible
military planning without ammunition
without food the whole thing comes to a
grinding halt and logistics actually in
the Falklands War tended to drive the
way the war was fought and and many of
our plans revolved round could you
actually do it logistically this small
port used by the military in Southampton
offers a guaranteed route for supplies
in and out of the UK if commercial ports
experience delays teams trained in
handling Freight could help transport
extra material to Gibraltar and Cyprus
if required a number of military
personnel have already been moved from
their normal jobs to focus on No Deal
preparations this isn't a sign that
defense Chiefs believe there will
definitely be problems but it is
evidence of the need for the Armed
Forces to be prepared in case there are
any disruptions military bases in the UK
are also building up their stores to
ensure troops don't run out of fuel or
food if there's any disruption to
imports but officers say cost-saving
cuts to improve efficiency in recent
decades have left the Armed Forces less
resilient having lots of everything is a
really inefficient way of doing business
and in the same way that we've seen the
NHS desiring not to hold two weeks worth
of particular drugs but having them only
two days but having a very efficient
just-in-time logistics supply chain so
the military has been doing similar
things that means that when there's a
bit more doubt and you need a bit more
flexibility you have to grow a bit of
fat on the bones a spokesman said a
limited range of supplies have been
bought as part of the mo DS contingency
planning
but he said March would port didn't
currently feature in preparations to
defense sources however told Sky News
the port is being considered what's in
no doubt is that the military is getting
prepared there behind Sky News